mara tremblay on se croisait vous et
moins une certaine époque dans une autre
vie sur la rue restèrent sur le plateau
mont royal je pense que vous aviez un
appartement là bas la main tendue de
l'époque et plus du tout la même
ça fait vingt ans ça fait maintenant
plus comment dompter la bête
oui a fallu vivre des choses il fallait
j'ai eu 2 enfants j'étais mère
célibataire j'ai eu et j'ai perdu ma
mère j'ai une dynastie polarité j'ai
traversé beaucoup de choses donc c'est
normal je pense d'eux pour rester
accroché à ses débuts tu passes de
jeunes est au rendez vous et c'est de
trouver comme à gauche à droite cherche
partout puis mon identité a toujours été
très très fort tous traversent a par
exemple lancé musical et personnel je
pense que j'ai pas perdu c'est juste
j'ai juste à 12,6 quelque chose que j'ai
appris j'ai appris à apprécier en droit
j'ai fait quand même un bon bout de
chemin depuis
et finalement je suis fier et je pense
que c'est important d'être fier de ce
qu'on a accompli au lieu de vouloir tout
en clair un opus est clair qu'ils plus
c'est ça devient cuisant le diagnostic
de bipolarité on entendait déjà parler
sans touches vous en parlez aussi
beaucoup ces dernières années justement
sur le dans le nouvel album il ya une
magnifique chanson on verra demain et
l'on sent la douleur on sent la
souffrance de la difficulté à marcher à
discuter à respirer dans cette chanson
là enfin c'est le huitième album n'a été
fait dans la douleur ou si sa peau est
évident du tout le temps avec ses 2
colonnes
[Musique]
non la fibromyalgie en plus c'est comme
deux maladies qui sont très très mal
traités il m'a reconnu et m'a lui c'est
que capte les deux qui sont entrés en
même temps c'est exactement ce que je
décris dans cette chanson là mais aussi
un peu d'espoir dans ce sens que quand
ça va vraiment très très très mal
on peut aussi juste respirer regarder sa
douleur leur regarder ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur de nos pieds attendre parce
que ce qui arrive tout le temps c'est
que le lendemain d'une autre journée on
se réveille on se repose puis on a
l'occasion de respirer à nouveau on a
l'occasion de reprendre qu'il faut les
énergie change pas ça vaut mieux donc on
verra demain
c'est un peu nos dan à l'espoir de oui
ça confie le port on le dit on est
capable de le dire il faut le dire mais
il faut se reposer la dame qui l'observé
parce que il ya toujours une nouvelle
journée qu'il commande
j'étais censure
je pense toujours posé la question
suivante comment faire des spectacles
avec de tel diagnostic
je pense que les équipes sont très
compréhensifs de toute façon il y aurait
pas de choses si je pouvais pas être
épaulé comme ça et j'avoue que ce que je
trouve difficile je fais une confidence
il fait personnel c'est d'abord la
misère à jouer c'est sûr que plus ça va
plus j'ai mal au bourget mal aux mains
j'ai mal j'ai mal dans tout le corps est
ce je trouve ça très difficile mais j'ai
transcende ce par la vois j'apprends
j'apprends a croisé ma voix d'une autre
façon est ce pour ça que ma voix change
beaucoup en baisse mais j'ai comme si
mon instrument passé c'est celui qui
vote qui vole je vais le garder jusqu'à
temps que je peux les garder ça chez moi
même fait pas mal donc oui c'est
difficile mais je pense qu'il faut
adapter c'est pas la fin du monde je
pendrai de montréal est il pire que
soient mes enfants sont en santé j'ai
fait de la musique toute magie ça fait
30 ans que je fais de la musique des
choses donc je garde ce à l'intérieur de
moi que j'ai mais si j'ai 50 ans et plus
dans une deux ans j'ai plus envie d
aller jusqu'à 3 heures du matin ça fasse
non plus que ça donne tout à dom bien
qui je reprends je prends le sommeil
relax et j'espère bien entouré de gens
qui veille à ce que je sois dorloter
[Musique]
et
toutes les épreuves que vous avez
traversé j'imagine que ça me permet de
relativiser tout ce qui se passe en ces
temps de pandémie un peu un peu mais je
vais aux traverses a beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de bouleversements que les gens
savent que j'ai monté mon gars ont
quitté la maison je pense que ça non
plus on en parle beaucoup syndrome du
nid vide pour marc célibataire c'est
très difficile à vivre
j'ai vendu ma maison donc j'étais en
train de vivre plein bouleversement
rencontré un homme extraordinaire qui me
permet de vivre en sainte communion avec
la nature qui est magnifique d'une
communion humaine aussi que j'ai jamais
vécu donc you lie à tout ce qui se passe
au travers la pandémie donc on dirait
que ma sagesse les seuils qui m'ont été
inculquées par ma mère qui était très
sage et de me dire prendre en ce temps
là pour espérer prendre ce temps là pour
te poser pour être capable d'après
revenir puis offrir ma musique parce que
mon équipe ait pu offrir qu'un titre au
long des dix quand autour de la ferme
[Musique]
mara tremblay merci mille fois quelques
heures c'est un grand plaisir pour moi
merci
[Musique]